hello everybody hope they are good I'm
testing something a bit different here
something new um don't worry the usual
daily Bitcoin updates are not going
anywhere that is still of course going
to be the main content of this channel
but as well as those type of videos then
I'm thinking about starting this new
section in the YouTube channel and need
to talk about the news announcements
that surround the crypto market and of
course the thing that now everybody's
talking about because we're seeing loads
of news about this is the Bitcoin spot
ETF and I would like to make a video
about this so anybody that is not uh
familiar with what an ETF is and the
implications and how it works then maybe
this video can help them to understand
uh what it actually is okay so the first
question is what is a Bitcoin ETF and to
answer this question first we have to
talk about how we buy Bitcoin right now
so to buy Bitcoin now first you have to
open an account in an exchange so you
have to trust an exchange then uh it
gives you a wallet address you have to
deposit some money and then you can buy
Bitcoin in a spot through the app or
through the website so it's a bit
complex and it sets a barrier for new
potential buyers or investors so yes
it's kind of a problem now through a
Bitcoin ETF you wouldn't have to do all
of this imagine if you could buy or you
could invest in Bitcoin through a share
okay like in the stock market because in
the stock market if you buy a share then
you're buying a share of a company
through an ETF you can invest in assets
or an index so for example right now we
have the ETFs of I don't know gold oil
so imagine if you had an ETF of Bitcoin
and you wouldn't have to do all of these
of opening account in an exchange
depositing some money buy through the
exchange IM manine if you could just
literally go to the stock market and
invest in Bitcoin okay imagine how many
new investors and new budgers would come
okay that would be a great advant
Vantage and that would pump the Bitcoin
market cap okay that's a fact but now
you have to understand the difference
between a Bitcoin spot ETF and a Bitcoin
Futures ETF in a Bitcoin spot ETF the
asset manager will have to hold as much
Bitcoin as the ETF is worth and that's
going to trigger a new wave of
institutional holding of Bitcoin that
means that asset managers such as uh
blackrook Fidelity they are trying to
issue this Bitcoin spot ETF are going to
have to buy and hold Bitcoin of course
this is something positive and it's
something bullish but in my opinion in
the long term and by long term I mean
when these ETFs get approved and you
start to see Black Rock Fidelity Invesco
starting to pick up Bitcoin and holding
so then the crypto market cap can
increase um some experts are already
saying that if the actual crypto market
cap is around $1 trillion then it can go
to three4 trillion uh with this ETF news
so so uh we'll see what happens of
course these are only predictions that
some uh journalists or experts are
making we don't really know the reach is
going to it's going to have but for sure
it looks positive okay in the long term
and I say long term because if you were
one of these asset managers then let me
ask a question when would you like to
buy Bitcoin and I think that the answer
would be well when it's cheaper okay
when it's cheap and right now Bitcoin is
at
27k so um I don't know I think it would
make more sense to see Bitcoin dumping
first to I'm I'm not telling you new
lows okay but why not 20K 19k 18K why
not okay and then that's where the these
asset managers or these ETF providers
can pick up Bitcoin cheap and they can
hold it for the next Bull Run okay then
you're going to have a new wave of
investors and everybody is going to make
money so that's why it makes sense to me
first uh it might be a bit uh trixy what
I'm trying to say but uh I don't know
with everybody being bullish I know that
this opinion uh is not going to be liked
but yes I think with this news it would
make sense to see some manipulation
first see Bitcoin uh going lower before
they kind of start to pick up Bitcoin
and then we have the new bull room
probably next year around summer okay
according to the 4 year cycle so that's
what I think at the moment now what are
the ETF pros and cons well the pros are
clear you know you have more exposure
because you're going to have a new wave
of companies and individuals investing
and buying Bitcoin it's safer and less
complex because you don't need to open
an account in an exchange you can
literally do in the stock market and it
also reduces the transaction cost okay
right now in the exchanges you have to
uh pay two fees one when you open the
position and one when you close the
position so and in the stock market you
usually pay the fee once not not twice
so of course uh it reduces the
transaction cost and also uh the cons
are uh what I thought very quickly is
that more regulations means less
volatility okay so uh trading might
change a bit in the next few years we'll
see how how it looks what happens but uh
yes it should have uh in principle less
volatility after we see more regulations
okay and of course you have to talk
about the important use of the grayscale
win version is the SEC and these news
are huge because the SEC argument to
reject all these ETFs applications for
the last year was that the that these
ETFs are not designed to prevent
fruit and the court said that the
argument is wrong it's not valid so now
the ACC have a 45 days appeal period um
so the question is are they going to
appeal or not and uh I think the the
next question is uh in my opin opinion
the
key and is that if the ACC is going to
try to find new arguments to deny
applications okay I personally think
that this is the most likely thing um I
don't know if you guys remember a few
minutes ago I was telling you about how
the Bitcoin spot ETF ETF works so the
asset manager have to buy and hold uh
the amount of uh Bitcoin that the ETF is
worth and they don't don't hold it okay
there is a third party a custodian that
has to hold that Bitcoin okay so maybe
that new argument it's about the
custodian okay that's what I think it's
likely and then if that doesn't happen
and they just approve ETF that's what
crypto Twitter is celebrating and crypto
Twitter is expecting uh which I'm not
sure at all I don't think this is going
to happen if I'm honest with you I don't
think the ACC is going to give up now
and say okay I'm going to start
approving ETFs I don't think that's
likely okay I think I'm going to give a
bit more of a fight and try to find new
arguments but if crypto Twitter and the
moon Bo are right and they start to
approve ETFs right now are they going to
approve some of them or all of them and
that takes me to the next uh slide here
and are the deadlines okay this um
picture is from AR Roba J safe on on X
on Twitter and it's very interesting I
think it's a blue blomberg uh analyst
and these are the death lines for the
ETF issues okay and you can see there
that this week on Thursday and Friday
specially we have the first deathline of
some of these ETFs so I mean crypto
Twitter is expecting that this get
approved uh I tell you in advance don't
expect that at all okay it's more likely
again that they try to find a new
argument or they appe you but this uh
first deadline should probably get uh
delayed probably to the second deadline
then we'll see that's in October but uh
I just watched this morning an interview
with one of these ETF providers
CEOs and it was uh bitwise this one
bitwise Bitcoin ET ETP trust okay and he
was saying that he's expecting uh of
course the deadline to get uh postponed
uh now in the SEC and and he's expecting
an approval to take place in the next 5
to 6 months and that would take us to
2024 maybe in the third deadline that's
in January or even maybe in the final
deadline in March okay so probably in
January or in March 5 to 6 months that's
when it's more likely that we start to
see ETFs getting approved if they get
approved okay which is the more likely
because you have there uh some big boys
like Black Rock Fidelity that they have
some power also in the parliament so of
course um the big boys always win right
um that's what I think the DFS are going
to get approved but not without the SEC
to give some more of a fight first and
that would be to find uh new arguments
to reject them again okay and maybe take
us to the third death line or so so this
is pretty much I want to tell you about
this uh ETF news I don't know if it was
clear I hope that it helped you to
understand a bit what it's going on and
I probably talk more about this in in
Twitter so so if you are interested
about this topic then you can go to on
Twitter uh not only on my Twitter there
is uh again for example uh J safe he
talks about this a lot and other analyst
so if you want more information about
this then I think X or Twitter is your
place okay so thank you so much for
watching guys and I see you soon